this is the second time we get to honor
and celebrate South Asian Excellence how
meaningful is it to have this event
returned
um I'm so grateful that we've had the
ability to not just return but do it in
such an amazing capacity and be hosted
by Paramount Pictures I mean this is
Iconic and to be able to look around me
and see my peers and colleagues that
have hustled and founded the pavement
for years and to be able to have them
receive a moment that's just theirs
makes me like cry so and I hope it's a
moment that turns into a movement you
know because that's what we're hoping
because we're a movement so we
we're a movement it doesn't get more
glamorous than this what can we expect
tonight well I think
he looks really great performances from
Priyanka is really about Shining Light
on other people tonight she wants to
shine light on the norm she's been
saying that to me all week some amazing
movies that are nominated this year this
night is about the nominees and you'll
see a lot of them coming in um so this
will be about giving them the stage and
giving them a moment showcasing a little
bit of the movies and championing them
as the Oscars come back kick off for the
weekend you're co-hosting with your pal
Mindy I mean I know you guys have a lot
of Comedy shops between the two of you
but you also have known each other for a
long time what has who hasn't meant to
you to have a friend like Mindy in this
business I mean we both can mostly you
know we talk about the bad stuff like
when bad stuff happens we call each
other and I've noticed that yeah we'll
meet at like holy parties or Diwali or
you know parties and social events but
we actually call each other when she
goes down and we're like I'm not feeling
good about this and you know she helps
me through it and she's like I'm not
feeling good about it we have it's so
nice to have like
you know when girls have each other's
backs and especially to have that with
someone who comes from where I do and
even though we've had very culturally
very different experiences
um but it's just wonderful to have that
The Sisterhood right that's what it all
is and now do events like this get
harder when you have a little one at
home or is multi secretly backstage
no she's asleep oh my God can you
imagine
exactly no tonight's Daddy and Mommy's
night out we'll enjoy it
[Music]